Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 3 of CME 296.
So today is a very
special day because we're
going to talk about
flow matching, which
is a generation paradigm that
is quite trendy these days.
So if you're a member,
lectures 1 and lecture 2
were also about
generation paradigm
where we talked about diffusion
with DPM and lecture 1
and score matching in lecture 2.
So flow matching is yet
another generation paradigm.
And we're going to
see in this lecture
what is the mindset behind
that separate paradigm
and how it relates to
diffusion and score matching.
So as usual we're going to
start the class with a recap
of the last episodes.
So if you remember
lecture 1, we saw
how we could
generate new samples,
and the way we thought
about doing that
was taking images from
our training set, which
we named clean images.
And what we did is that we
gradually corrupted them
with a process that we
defined, a process q,
which, given an image
at a given time step,
noised it by adding some
Gaussian noise weighted
by some coefficients.
And the goal of diffusion
with DPM was to find
or was to learn a
reverse process, which
we noted p theta that
removed the noise gradually.
And what we saw was that
in order to learn p theta.
What we did is try to maximize
the likelihood of our model
seeing the training data.
And if you remember,
we did some clever math
with some estimation
of the lower bound.
So the elbow and we
derived some terms
and we ended up
with a pretty good
looking loss, which was just an
L2 regression on the noise that
was added up to the
image at timestamp t.
And so this was lecture 1.
Lecture 2 was taking
another perspective
and just taking a
step back, thinking
of images in the space of the
n dimensional space of images,
and the fact that
what we wanted to do
was sample from an
easy distribution
and then work our way up until
the true data distribution.
So how did we do that?
The whole point
of the lecture was
to learn what we call
the score, which is
the gradient of the log of p.
And why did we do that?
Because it acted as
a compass from where
we were up until
regions of high density.
And if we learn such a
score, what we could do
was use sampling techniques
such as Langevin sampling, which
allowed us to move towards
high density regions,
but also allow for some
diversity with some noise term.
And we saw that in order for
us to estimate that score,
we cleverly noised the initial
data distribution in order
to learn the score of
the noised distribution.
And then we had a
progressive noise schedule
that allowed us to
progressively work our way up
until the data distribution.
So we ended up with
a score function
that was a function of
the position in space,
but also the noise level.
And again, after doing
some clever math,
we also ended up with an
L2 regression loss, which
was quite easy to compute.
But what we also saw was
that what we saw in lecture 2
was actually quite related
to what we saw in lecture 1,
because both involved
adding noise.
And in particular,
we saw that there
was a relationship between the
score of a noisy distribution
and the noise that we
added from the clean image
to the noisy image.
So given that, what
we did was think
of a unified way of looking
at both these perspectives,
and we moved from a
discrete representation
to a continuous one, and
we obtained this SDE, which
was of the form dx equal f
of x and t dt plus gt times
dw, where w is our Wiener
process which is introducing
the stochasticity.
And in particular, the first
term is called the drift term,
and it is a term that quantifies
the deterministic movement
in space across time.
And the second term is
called the diffusion term,
which quantifies the
amount of stochasticity
that you have in your process.
So this expression is the
expression of the forward pass,
meaning, you're actually
noising your images.
And we saw that in
space, if we were
to represent that,
it meant, again,
having a drift component
and a diffusion component.
So now if we wanted
to denoise our image,
we were actually interested
in the reverse process,
which we saw thanks to the
result from the '80s involved
knowing the score.
So this expression is
the reverse process
that allows us to
denoise images, which is
why we need to learn the score.
And this is where
the score comes in,
in the continuous view.
So this was two weeks
ago and a week ago.
But today we're going to see
this third generation paradigm,
which is called flow matching.
And similar to the
past lectures, what
we're going to try
to do is to have
a nice balance between
intuition and math,
because you will see that
these papers are full of math,
full of equations,
and we will try
to approach it from an
intuitive perspective,
but not shy away
from the math either.
And of course, please
interrupt me at any point
if you feel there's
something that's not clear.
Cool?
OK, let's start.
So the whole point of
these first three lectures
is to find a way to
go from somewhere
that is easy to sample
from up until our data
distribution of interests.
So the way that flow
matching works is.
It has two distributions.
The first one is called
the initial distribution,
which is the distribution
that you're starting from.
And then the second distribution
is called the target
distribution, and it
is the distribution
that you want to end up with.
And the whole point
of flow matching
is finding a way to transport
our initial data distribution up
until the target distribution.
And just note the terminology
I'm using, transport.
So what we want is to transport
the whole density that we have,
and remember that
probability, densities
have this very nice
property of summing to 1.
So we want to transport the
whole density distribution
from one place to another.
So this is the idea
behind flow matching.
And we're going to see
how we can do that.
So I'm going to just give you a
warning in terms of conventions.
In the past, we've seen
that 0 was clean data
and then capital T
was the noise data.
But here it's going
to be different.
So we will be noting p0 our
initial data distribution, which
is typically something
that is easy to sample
from such as Gaussian noise.
And the target data
distribution is
going to be noted p1,
t equal 1, and this is
where we want to end up with.
And then again, so
this slide is just
to say that lectures 1
and 2 we said 0 was clean,
capital T was noise.
But here 0 will be noise
and 1 will be what we want,
which is the clean images,
which is the data distribution.
So the reason why we
chose to proceed that way
is just that the field
chose these conventions.
And if we were to keep the
conventions of the diffusion
and score matching fields,
it would just completely
confuse if you were to read
papers from the flow matching
field, which is the reason
why we're keeping things
consistent with the paper.
But just keep those
things in mind,
because sometimes these
conventions can also
be reversed, depending on
which paper you're reading.
But this one is by
far the most common.
So with that warning
aside, what we want to do
is to sample an observation from
our initial data distribution
and then map it to the
target data distribution.
So in order to do
that, we're now
going to go through
some common notations.
And the first one is
called the trajectory.
So the trajectory is
notated xt, and it
is the path that is taken by
an observation between times 0
and 1.
So by the way, the time
0 and 1 is arbitrary.
It's just a way for us to
say, OK, when are we starting
and when are we ending?
And so here at time t
equals 0, we have x0.
And what we want to do
is for our trajectory
to map a point from
p0 up until p1.
So that's our goal.
So now, let's see
another notation.
So this one is called the flow.
The flow is known
as psi of T of x0.
So I'm just going to
write that down here.
So it is a function that takes
time and an initial condition.
And it gives you where
that point at time t.
So this is the time
so belongs to 01.
This one is to your
space, which is maybe--
I don't know-- d dimensional.
And this one is also in
the d dimensional space.
And you have psi
of T of x0, which
is equal to your point at
time t, which is x of t.
So the flow you can interpret
it in different ways.
So one way you can
interpret it is it's
a collection of trajectories.
Because if you change
the initial condition x0,
then psi t of x0 is all
the possible trajectories
that go from an initial
condition x0 up until time t.
Yeah?
The flow can also be
seen as a function that
maps your initial condition to
where it should be at time t.
And this is why it's
called the flow.
So this function
is quite important
because at the end
of the day, what
you want is psi 1 of x0 to be
sampled from-- to be as if it
was sampled from p1, which is
your target distribution, data
distribution.
Cool.
So now we have our
next terminology
which is called the probability
path, and it's denoted pt of x.
So pt of x is the
probability distribution
of your observations at time t.
So p0 of x is your initial
data distribution, and p1 of x
is your target
data distribution.
So if t is between 0
and 1, it's basically
the intermediary probability
data distribution.
And as you can imagine, in
order to go from p0 to p1,
you have an infinite
number of ways
of going from one to the other.
So pt by no means unique.
There are many ways for
you to go from 0 to 1.
Cool.
And now we're going to
talk about a central object
of this whole field, and
it's called the vector field.
So vector field
is noted ut of x.
And it is a function that takes
in a place in space, so x,
and a time t.
And it gives you a vector.
And that vector,
you can interpret it
as the direction and the speed
that particles should move
at that location at that time.
So again, the vector
field takes in a vector,
which is your position
in space and gives you
also a vector, which is where
you need to move and how fast.
And we're going to see
that the vector field is
quite central to flow matching.
But before we do that,
I know last lecture,
we talked about the score.
And the score was also a vector.
And if you remember,
the score was also
something we used in order
to go from noise to data.
So one natural question you may
be asking yourself right now
is, well, how does this vector
field or velocity relate
to the score?
So I'm going to give you
the following analogy.
So let's suppose you want to go
from your initial distribution
to your target distribution.
And let's suppose
that you're thinking
of this in terms of self-driving
cars that are distributed,
let's say, in a Gaussian fashion
in the middle of the desert.
And what you want to do is to
position your self-driving cars
in a certain way so that
it follows, let's say,
a target data distribution.
So the way you would
think of the velocity
would be instructions
that you would
give to your self-driving
cars at a given location
and at a given time t So if
the vector field was not time
dependent, you could even think
of it as highways or routes
with speed limits.
But here, the vector
field is actually
time dependent, which means that
at a given location x and at two
different time steps, t1 and
t2, that vector can actually
be different.
And in that sense,
just following
with that self-driving
car example,
the score would be
a bit like a compass
that you could see in your
car of where high density
regions are.
So I hope this is
useful to just picture
the difference between what a
velocity is and what a score is.
So these two are
vectors, but they
have different interpretations.
Any questions so far?
We've barely started, so we're
going to see a few things here.
But I just want to make sure
that the notation so far are
clear.
Yeah, all good?
Cool.
So we're going to see
our first identity here.
So we introduced the vector
field, a.k.a. the velocity,
because this is the way we're
going to have our particles
move from one place to another.
And in particular,
the definition
we're giving to the velocity,
a.k.a. the vector field,
is given as follows.
So what we're going to say
is that a change in position
will be associated with the
velocity at that location
at that time t times dt.
So in other words, a given
particle in a given location
will be moving according
to that velocity.
And one thing that
I want to tell you
is that the trajectory,
which as a reminder,
is the whole path that the
particle is taking from time t
equals 0 to time t equal to
1, that trajectory is actually
going to be unique for a
given initial condition
if there is a special condition
on the vector field, which
is that if the vector field
is Lipschitz continuous.
So the reason why
I'm bringing this up
is because it's going
to be important.
And so who knows what
Lipschitz continuity is?
Have you ever
heard of this term?
Yeah?
No?
OK, so maybe I can just recap
the mathematical definition
and maybe how it
means-- what it means.
So Lipschitz continuity
of a function f
is when you have some
constants, let's call
it m such that for all x and
y in your space of interest,
you have your function f that
satisfies this relationship.
So the norm of f of x
minus f of y is less than
or equal than m times
the norm of x minus y.
So what this means is that f
needs to be continuous, but also
not in a very dramatic way.
So this is the
mathematical definition
of Lipschitz continuity.
And what I'm saying here
is if the vector field
is Lipschitz continuous,
then the trajectories x
will be unique for a
given initial condition.
And so I'm going
to just give you
an example of when
trajectories are not unique.
So here we have our ODE
which is here like so.
So I'm just going to give you an
example of if we have a vector
field that is not Lipschitz
continuous, how we can have
trajectories that start
from the same point
but that are actually different.
So here, the example
is as follows.
So let's suppose
we have your vector
field, which is given this, by,
let's say, square root of x.
And you only consider, by
the way, x positive or 0.
So if your vector field, by
the way, is time independent
and it's just a function of
x by square root of x, then
if you say you want your
initial condition to be x0
is equal to 0, then xt equal
to 0 is going to be a solution,
but xt equals to
t squared over 4
is also going to be a solution.
So here t squared over 4.
So the derivative is t over 2.
And here's when you put this
also in the square root,
it's also t over 2.
So all of that to say that
your vector field needs
to behave in a
certain way if you
want to guarantee that your
trajectories are unique.
And this is
Lipschitz continuity.
And you're going to
see why that matters.
Cool.
So that's the first equation
that's going to be important.
So the ODE here,
which is dx over dt
is equal to the velocity
at location x and time t.
It's the first one.
The second one that we're
going to see is the following.
So I told you that
what we want to do
is transport our distribution
from one place to another.
So when you transport
something, one thing
that you want to guarantee
is that you're not
going to lose or gain anything
of what you're transporting.
You have what we call
conservation of mass.
And this idea is also something
we want to put in writing.
And in particular, we're going
to focus on the following case.
So let's assume you're
in a region of space
and you consider
a very small area.
And here you have your data
distribution that is around it.
So the equation that we
want to put in writing
is around making sure that
the evolution of your density
at time t is equal
to the density that
is coming minus the density that
is going out or that is leaving.
Do you all agree with this idea?
So the evolution of
density as at time t
is a function of how
much density comes
in minus how many comes out.
So the left-hand
side is kind of easy.
It's just a partial derivative
of your probability path
at that region with
respect to time.
But then the right side, I don't
about you, but very intuitively,
there's not like a supernatural
operator that does that.
So what we're
going to see now is
how we can quantify the
idea on the right side
of the equal sign.
But before we do that, I
just want to take a pause.
Does this idea make sense,
conservation of mass?
By the way, have you
seen it in another topic?
Yeah?
So in physics, you
have the same thing,
and it's actually
called-- it has a name.
It's called the
continuity equation.
Anyways, so instead of just
giving you the formula,
we're just going to
intuitively get to it.
And in particular, I want us to
think about this right-hand side
of this equation
and think for a bit
how we want to quantify the
inflow minus outflow bit.
So let's suppose you
have an operator that's
called of the divergence.
But right now, I'm not
telling you anything
about what that operator is.
I'm just telling you that
the operator is positive
when things are coming
out more than coming in.
And we're going to
see what happens then.
So here, when we're talking
about coming in and coming out,
we're, of course,
talking about vectors.
So here we're
assuming, for instance,
if there's more coming
out than coming in that--
let's assume if we are
in one dimensional space,
you have a vector that is
such that at first it's
small in magnitude, and then
it's much bigger in magnitude.
So here, do you agree
with me that whatever
this vector is
representing, there is more
coming out than coming in?
You all agree?
OK, so that's one
case where coming out
can be more than coming in.
So let's see a second case.
So second case is here.
And then let's say your vector
is coming out here and coming
out there.
Yeah?
I'm sure you can have
more cases than that.
But in this 1D example, if you
were to represent your vector,
let's say f, over the
dimension x, here,
what is the
magnitude of f doing?
It is increasing.
OK, so here, we just see that
partial derivative of x/x
is increasing.
How about here?
So here it's negative.
And then it becomes positive.
Also increasing, right?
OK, so based on this very
back-of-the-envelope intuition,
we see that when
things are leaving,
partial derivative of x over
this dimension of f over this
dimension x is positive, which
seems to match the sign that we
want from our
divergence operation.
So now let's see the other case.
So let's assume that we have
now the case where we want
our operator to be negative
when there is, quote unquote,
"more coming than leaving."
So here again, this example.
So you have, let's say, a
bigger vector here coming
and then a smaller one leaving.
And then let's say you
have another case, which
is given by this, which
is just vectors pointing
towards that area.
So here you see that f is
becoming more and more negative
when you project it on x.
So here you have
partial derivative
of f over x, which is negative.
And here you see that
it was first positive,
and then it becomes negative,
which again, boils down to this.
So this is by no
means a formal proof,
but I hope I gave you some
intuition that if you take
the partial derivative of your
function that is outputting
a vector over its
coordinates, at least in 1D,
it would give you this
intuition that if it's positive,
then it's more coming out,
and when it's negative,
then there's more coming in.
So based on this intuition,
what I'm now telling
you is that there is an
operator that is indeed
called the divergence that is
a function of a vector, that
is a function of x, which
is also multidimensional.
And what it is
doing is it is just
the sum of the partial
derivatives of x
over each dimension.
So the divergence is a scalar.
It's a number.
And if it's positive,
it just means that there
are more things coming out.
And if it's negative, it means
there are more things coming in.
So based on that, we want to see
how we can use this divergence
operator back into our
continuity equation example,
where we want to quantify
the fact that we want
the net inflows, which
is how much density
is coming in versus out.
So now a second
question is something
that we ask ourselves, which
is OK, what should we use as f?
What should f be?
So we saw the
vector field, which
is a vector that
could be a candidate.
So do you think the vector
field could be a good candidate?
So let's see with an example.
So let's suppose you
have two points in space,
let's say x1 and x2.
And then you have their
respective vector fields.
If you happen to have a higher
density in one of the two
points, then our
intuition tells us
that you would want the point
in the higher density region
to transport more things than
the one in the lower density
region.
So in that case, the vector
field alone would actually not
be a good candidate.
Instead, and maybe you
have guessed it, in order
to quantify the movement
of density, we, of course,
need to take into consideration
the probability density.
And so here the actual
quantity that we will use
is called the
probability flux, and it
is defined by dt,
which is a scalar times
ut, which is the vector field.
So going back to
the equation that we
wanted to put in writing,
what we're saying
is that the temporal evolution
of the density at time t, which
we said is simply the partial
derivative of p with respect
to t.
We're now saying that this is
equal to minus the divergence
of the probability flux.
And this quantity, so minus
divergence of dt ut of x.
It just means that we're
interested in the net inflows
of density within
our small volume.
So all in all, that equation,
which I'm going to write,
is nothing else than the
continuity equation, which
you may have seen in physics.
So I'm going to write it down.
And of course, OK, this is here.
So what we're saying is that the
evolution of density at a given
location, the temporal evolution
of the density at a given
location, is given by how much
density is coming in minus
how much density is coming out.
And this just conveys
the facts that we're not
creating new density
out of thin air,
we're just conserving it
when time goes from t0 to 1.
And compared to the
ODE that we saw before,
you can think of this
equation as being
a macro perspective of how
your probability path evolves.
And the ODE itself
is actually centered
on how one particle
evolves, which
is more a micro perspective,
which we're going to see here.
So a single sample, you take
your sample x at time t.
And what you're saying is that
how fast that particle is going
is actually given
by the vector field
at that location at that time.
So the distance dx is
given by ut of x times dt.
So this is the
micro perspective.
But we also saw that
this vector field that
was coming into the picture
in this micro perspective
is also in the
macro perspective.
And what we're saying is
given that we're transporting
the density and we're not
losing it or gaining it,
we also have this nice
identity that we can use,
which is also called
the continuity equation.
And so there is expression that
you will see a lot in papers.
I'm going to read it out loud.
The vector field ut of x
generates the probability path.
So when people say
that, what they mean
is that ut and dt satisfy
the continuity equation.
So now you may wonder,
well, why should we care?
So just remember
that our goal is
to sample an observation from
the initial distribution p0,
and to map it to the
target data distribution.
And the way we want
to map it is we
want that particle
to go from one place
to another using
the vector field.
And so what we want is to find
a probability path that will
allow us to go from p0 to p1.
And in order to find
the probability path,
we also need to find the
associated vector field that
will allow us to actually do
the mapping because that vector
field is in the single
sample perspective.
So that's the idea.
We're going to see it in
other words, in a little bit.
But this is the intuition
behind flow models.
Any questions on this?
Everything is clear so far?
Yep.
So question is the
solution of this equation
would be the target.
So on the left-hand
side, if we know ut
and if we know that ut is
allowing pt to go from p0,
something that we decide
that is easy to sample
to p1, what we care
about, what we're saying
is if we know such a ut,
then on the left-hand side,
if you sample x from p0, you
have your initial condition.
And if you ut,
what that means is
you can solve this equation
in order to find x1.
And x1, by definition, will be
as if it was sample from p1.
So that's the idea.
I know it was a lot.
I know it may not seem
clear, but don't worry,
we have a lot of
examples down the line.
So let's move on.
Oh, this is exactly my
next slide actually.
So here what we're saying is the
relationship between these two
perspectives, I'm
going to just repeat
what I said but in
mathematical terms,
is if we sample x0 from p0.
Given that our particle
x is subject to velocity,
then what that means is, if
that velocity is actually
generating the probability path
from the initial to the target
one, then what that means is
that xt will be sampled from dt.
And in particular, t=1, x1
will be sampled from p1.
OK, cool.
So don't worry.
We're going to go into
more details on this.
So the whole goal of flow models
is to map points, is to map x0
to x1.
So what is our strategy here?
We saw that the vector
field was a central piece
of this whole problem.
So number one,
step number one is
for us to estimate this
vector field via some model
that we're going to
note ut theta of x.
So theta is the parameters
that we're learning.
So if we learn such
a vector field,
then what we're going to
do in order to map x0 to x1
is we're going to use the
ODE and solve it numerically.
So what does that mean?
That means that we're
going to sample x0,
and we're just going to
follow the vector field up
until time equal to 1.
So this integral
here in practice
is going to be just a numerical
solver that maybe Euler,
for instance.
And it's going to be giving
you x1, which is what you want,
because at the end of the day,
you want to be able to sample
from your target
data distribution.
So starting from
now, our full focus
will be around finding the
vector field ut theta of x.
Because right now, I just
told you what we care about.
But I didn't tell you how
we're going to do that.
So now we're going
to focus on that.
So in the past, there
has been many papers
published on how you can
estimate your vector field.
And there is one method that
I'm going to mention here,
which is not going to be
the focus of this class
because it is a method that
was used a number of years ago.
So eight years ago, I believe.
But it is not something that
could be used in practice.
So people are not
using it so far.
But I'm just telling you
just for historical purposes.
So one way of learning
the vector fields
is by maximizing the likelihood
that your model is seeing
the data, the training set.
So how can you do that?
Well, if you take the
continuity equation that we saw,
so this one--
so if you take this
equation, then what happens
is if you do some
math, you can actually
pop up that log
of dt of x, which
is what you want to maximize.
And you can have the
following strategy.
So you want to determine
log of p1 of x1.
So x1 is the data
from the training set.
So you want to compute the
probability of your model
seeing x1.
The problem is you
don't how to compute it.
So the way you're going
to do this is you're
first going to realize that
you can compute the probability
that the initial distribution
is seeing x0, because typically,
the initial distribution is an
easy one, something that you
can analytically compute,
such as a Gaussian.
So you know how to
compute log p0 of x0.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to link x1 and
x0 by integrating
the divergence of the vector
fields, because you have--
the formula above that is true.
So if you know log p0 of x0 and
if you know the vector field,
then you can compute
this quantity.
And so what that
paper was doing,
which is called continuous
normalizing flow,
was that it was us trying to
learn the parameters theta
by maximizing the likelihood
of your training sets
happening under theta.
And it was computing the
likelihood using this formula.
So what is the problem?
The problem is that
at training time,
you need to constantly
solve this integral.
So it's a numerical solver
that works all the time.
So it's very expensive
and very slow,
which is why we
have a snail emoji.
So it's just not practical.
People just couldn't use that.
And for that
reason, I hope I did
a good job of motivating
the reason why
we needed another approach.
The approach we're
going to see now
is actually what is called
flow matching, because we're
going to see we're not doing
maximum likelihood estimation.
We're instead trying to
directly learn the vector field.
So if you remember
for score matching,
you were directly trying
to learn the score.
So here we're directly trying
to learn the vector field.
But the problem is that
you don't know what it is.
So we're going to see how
we can compute this loss
and indeed optimize on theta in
order to find our vector field.
So just remember that the
problem that we have is we
have an initial data
distribution and a target data
distribution.
And what we care
about is finding
this ut of x, which will
allow us to go from p0 to p1.
That is our goal.
Well, p0 is easy, so it's
a Gaussian typically.
But then p1 can be
super complicated.
So one idea we can
have is what if we just
remember that the target
data distribution is just
composed of points from
your training data?
So it's like individual points.
So what if instead we
simplify our problem
and we ask ourselves how we
can transport the initial data
distribution, not to the target
one, but to a single point?
How about if we just move
our whole data distribution
from initial to a single point?
And here, I noted
the single point
with the distribution delta x1.
So delta x1 is the notation
for a Dirac delta distribution.
So who has heard of
the Dirac distribution?
Yeah?
So Dirac distribution
is actually probably
the simplest
distribution out there
because it's a
deterministic distribution.
It will always give
you one quantity.
So here delta-- so I'm
going to write it down.
So delta x1 of x is going to
be 0 if x is different than x1.
And otherwise, it will be
actually a very high number.
So typically, people
say, let's say infinity.
But of course, it's
infinity, but the integral
of this distribution, like
the density needs to be 1.
So long story short is that
we simplified our problem
from initial data distribution
to your target one.
So we changed from that
formulation to initial data
distribution to a single point.
So one idea could be for us
to think of the following way
of going from one to the other.
So let's suppose you
have a probability
path that is super simple.
It's just a Gaussian
distribution
that is being interpolated
between 0 and x1.
So here what I'm saying is,
how about we think of the way
we want to go from
0 to the points
by taking our normal
distribution of mean 0
and variance identity?
And how about we
just scale it down,
scale it down and then
move it towards x1
until it becomes
just that point?
So here pt-- so we say
x given x1, because it's
a conditional probability, it's
like given we're arriving at x1
at time t equal 1, it will
be given by a mean of t x1
and a variance of 1 minus
t squared times identity.
So let me tell you
why that is the case.
So what I'm saying here is
that I'm proposing a way for us
to go from the normal
distribution that
is this one of mean 0 and
then variance the identity.
So what I'm saying is in order
to go from here to this point,
which is x1, what
I'm telling you
is we're going to have a
path pt given x1, which
is a normal distribution of--
as a function of t because it's
probability path at time t,
t x1 and 1 minus t squared I.
So when t equals 0, this
is 0, this is identity.
So p0 is just the
normal distribution of 0
and I. And p1 is--
well, t=1 is just x1.
And this one is a variance of 0.
So you can think of
t just tending to 0.
So p1 is just a
Dirac distribution.
So this probability path
that I'm telling you
is something that is letting
us go from our initial data
distribution to this point.
So it's a valid one.
So why am I choosing this?
Well it can be shown that
one vector field that
is generating this
probability path
has the following expression.
So ut of x given x1 is x1
minus x over 1 minus t.
So I'm just giving you the
formula so you can derive it.
So I'm looking at the time,
we will not have time.
But the reason why I proposed
the probability path,
the conditional
probability path is
because it's much easier for
us to compute a vector field,
and it's something that
we can actually write.
And it is this one.
And what I'm going
to tell you is
that this vector
field is generating
the conditional
probability path.
So in other words,
the vector field
will be such that if
you sample from p0
of this conditional
probability path,
and if you follow these
conditional vector fields,
what I am telling you
is that you will end up
at time equal t
with xt following
your conditional
probability path.
Well, that's a huge
step forward, no?
So how do you prove
that, by the way?
So you just use the quantities,
you use the vector field that
is just this formula, and you
use the conditional probability
paths which you can
analytically derive.
Because, if you remember
the Gaussian distribution,
we just know
everything about it.
We also know the
density formula.
So if you take both formula
and if you use the continuity
equation, which is
here, you can show
that this expression is true.
And this is how you prove that.
Now we're not going to do it
because this is just some math.
But maybe one thing
I will tell you
is why that vector
fields makes sense.
So we said that--
we said that the conditional
vector field, which
is noted ut of x
given x1, what we said
was that this was equal to
x1 minus x over 1 minus t.
Well, when t is approaching 1,
and when your x is not near x1,
then what you're seeing is
that this quantity goes crazy,
goes very close to infinity.
It goes very, very high.
Well, why does that make sense?
It's because at time t equal 1,
your distribution is literally
a deterministic
distribution that is x1.
So you want all your
particles to be exactly at x1.
So if you're not at x1,
then you better hurry.
Your velocity will
be very, very high.
So that's one thing
I want to say.
And one other
thing I want to say
is there is a very
nice expression
of the conditional
vector fields if xt
is drawn from that conditional
probability path, which
as a reminder, is a normal
distribution of mean t x1
and 1 minus t squared I.
So if xt is drawn from such
a conditional probability
path, that means that you
can express xt as follows.
So t x1 plus 1
minus t x0, with x0
drawn from a normal
distribution.
So what that means is
ut of xt, given x1,
if I were to just replace xt
in this formula, what I would
obtain is x1 minus--
so x, I'm just
going to directly replace just
because I don't have space.
So t x1 plus 1 minus
t x0 over 1 minus t.
So x1 minus t x1 is 1 minus
t times x1 minus 1 minus t
times x0 over 1 minus t.
So what that means this
is equal to x1 minus x0.
The conditional
vector field for xt,
which is drawn from a
conditional probability path,
is nothing else than x1
minus x0, which is very nice.
So why is it very nice?
Well, it's tractable and it's
going to be useful for us.
OK, any questions?
Yeah?
So the question is, how do
we get to that equation?
So the question is, where
does this equation come from?
So this one, the one
above is just an equation
that I'm just telling
you, I'm just giving you.
And you can verify
that it actually
is generating the
conditional probability path.
You can prove it, but
we're not doing it.
So given that this
part is just me
telling you that
this expression can
be even further simplified if
the x that you're putting here
is actually drawn from the
conditional probability path.
So as a reminder, the
conditional probability path
is given by a normal
distribution of mean t x1
and 1 minus t
squared I. So if you
were to draw from
such a distribution.
It would be the same
thing because you x1.
thing as sampling
from just a standard
normal Gaussian
and writing xt as follows,
because this is your variance,
this is the mean.
So this is the mean
plus the variance times
something that is run from
the normal distribution.
And so what I'm
telling you is if you
were to plug in that
expression in here,
then a lot of
simplifications occur.
And you end up with a
very simple expression
of the conditional vector
field at that point
being equal to just x1 minus
x0, where x0 is basically
this component of xt.
And follow up question is, well,
why are you telling me this?
It's a very fair question.
I'm going to tell
you in 15 minutes.
But does everyone
agree with me so far?
I'm going to take that as a yes.
OK, so now that we looked at a
very simple case of transporting
our data distribution from this
initial one to a single point,
now our goal is going to figure
out how we can map that back
to our initial problem.
So our initial problem is
to map from the initial data
distribution to the
target data distribution.
So an idea to obtain the
target data distribution
is to replicate this
conditional path
over all points of your
target data distribution.
So if we do that,
we consider, let's
say, one point of your
target data distribution,
we have this conditional
probability path.
We consider a second point.
And let's assume here that
our target data distribution,
our training set
only has two points.
Then what that means
is that at time t,
we can consider what we call
a marginal probability path.
So marginal because we
marginalize across the x1's.
And we will end up with
a mixture of Gaussians,
where each Gaussian
is interpolating
between the normal one
to the single point.
So let me tell you why I'm
telling you all of this.
So just remember that
what we care about
is to map our initial
distribution to the target one.
So there are many ways to
go from one to the other.
And what we say is
that we can just
propose this marginal
probability path, which I'm
going to explain in a second.
So what I'm telling
you is let's fix x1.
And just consider the
conditional probability path.
So p of x given x1
which is what we saw.
Before Now let's consider all
such conditional probability
path across all the x1's that
are composing our target data
distribution.
And let's consider the
following expression,
which is a natural
way of defining it.
So we notice that p0 of x--
so p0 of x, given x1 is just the
standard normal distribution,
p0.
So this is indeed the
initial data distribution.
So the standard Gaussian.
And p1, what is p1?
So we said that when t equals
1, p of x given x1 is the Dirac.
So when t equal 1, this one
is equal to Dirac of x1 at x.
So this whole thing
simplifies to P data of x.
So this marginal
probability path
is verifying p0,
like t equals 0,
is equal to your initial
data distribution.
And p1 is your target
So it is a valid path
to go from 0 to 1.
So now our goal-- because
just remember, what we want
is to go from 0 to 1.
And we want to learn
the vector field that
is getting us from 0 to 1.
So the good thing here is we
have a probability path that
is getting us from 0 to 1.
So now let's look
at the vector field.
Let's see if there
is a way for us
to aggregate the conditional
vector fields such
that it is going to enable
us to go from 0 to 1.
So here we consider the
conditional vector field
for each data point like
conditional on each data point.
So this one and this one.
And what we want is to
also have a marginal vector
field, something that
is able to generate
the marginal probability path.
And what I'm going
to tell you is
that the way we want to
aggregate the vector field
is going to actually
be quite intuitive.
So I'm going to
just write it down.
So up until now,
what we're doing is
we're constructing things.
We're constructing
things, and then we're
verifying that it's actually
something that is what we want.
So what I'm saying
is we're going
to aggregate the conditional
vector fields by considering
the following aggregation.
So I'm going to take my
conditional vector fields.
I'm going to aggregate
it as follows.
So I'm going to say
it's equal to this.
So the conditional probability
path times p data of x1
over the marginal
probability path which we
have derived a short while ago.
And I'm going to say that
this is my definition.
This is my proposed definition
of the marginal vector field.
So this expression
may seem scary to you,
but if you remember
Bayes' rule, this one--
you recognize Bayes'
rule here, a little bit?
So it's as if-- so I'm
going to put this in quotes.
So it's as if it was the
probability of x1 being
where you're headed given
x, which is where you are.
So the way you're aggregating
your conditional vector
fields is OK, I'm
at point x and I'm
going to weight each conditional
vector fields with a weight that
is telling me the probability
of this x1 being my destination
given where I am.
So you can think of this
as the posterior mean.
And this coefficient can
be interpreted as OK,
given where I am, how likely
is it that this point is
where I want to go?
And now I'm going to tell
you the biggest result.
These marginal vector
field which we defined
is actually generating
the probability path,
the marginal probability path.
So this is a big deal.
So what that means is there is a
vector field that is generating
the probability path that
is actually something that
satisfies what we want, which
is it's a path that goes
from the initial to the target.
So I'm looking at the time.
I'm not going to
derive it, but I'm
going to derive
something else instead.
So in order for you to show that
this vector field is generating
the probability path is by
just plugging these quantities
in the continuity equation.
So I'm not going to do it.
I'm just going to tell
you how you would do it.
So you just do that.
So you take your marginal
probability path.
You derive it here,
and just recognize
that it is indeed the
minus the divergence
of the marginal probability path
and the marginal vector field.
So what this is telling
us is if we sample x0
from p0, which is the initial
one, then if we follow
the marginal vector
field, then xt
is going to be following
the probability path p of t.
This is huge because
if you take x0
and you take it all the way to
t equal 1 with the vector field,
then x1 will be
actually following p1,
which is what you care about.
So this is huge.
This can be proven
mathematically.
We're not going to
do it with respect
to how much time we have.
And so this leads us
to our initial problem,
which is us wanting to learn
a vector field that will
allow us to go from p0 to p1.
So here, what I'm
going to tell you
is that optimizing for
the flow matching loss
that I told you at
the very beginning
is equivalent to you
optimizing for what
we call the conditional
flow matching
loss, which is given by here.
And I'm going to tell you more
about this for the next five
minutes.
So let me take this.
So here, what we want is
to have a tractable loss.
And if you look at the
flow matching loss,
it is still a loss
that is quite complex.
So our goal is to
really make our loss
as tractable as possible.
So as a result what
we're saying is
that the loss of
flow matching, which
is given by this, so
it's the expectation
of the squared distance
of your learned
vector field minus the
marginal vector field
that you constructed.
So what we're saying is
optimizing for the loss above
is the same as optimizing
for the conditional flow
matching loss,
which is this one.
So if we aggregate
over time steps t and x
drawn from the probability
path dt of this expression,
what I'm saying is that
optimizing for this loss
is the same as optimizing
for the conditional flow
matching loss, where the
expectation is over t x1,
and then x belonging to the
conditional probability path.
And back to your question.
This whole expression
that we had here
was ut of xt given x1,
which was x1 minus x0.
So this thing is super simple.
It is just the thing that you
want to learn minus x1 minus x0.
Super simple.
OK, so now why is it
equivalent to optimize
on the flow matching and the
conditional flow matching loss?
That's another question.
So if you remember,
for score matching,
we had a very similar question.
So I'm going to give
you the same trick.
So let's assume you have
distance squared of a minus
B, which is basically
what we have here.
And what you want is to optimize
these losses with respect
to the parameters
of the model theta.
So everything that you
care here is only terms
that are a function of theta.
So a minus b that norm squared
is equal to a squared minus 2
dot product of a and
b plus b squared.
So ut theta x squared,
this and this are the same.
Perfect.
So how about this term.
The b term is actually
not dependent on theta.
So we actually don't care.
So a is good.
It's the same.
b is not a function of theta.
We don't care.
The only thing that is
different between these two
is the dot product of a and b.
So this one and this one
and this one and this one.
So what we want to show
is the expectation over t
and x of this dot product is
the same as the expectation
over this.
So t x1 and x over the
conditional probability
part of this one and this one.
We want to show that
these two are the same.
So I'm going to do
this in two minutes.
OK.
So let's suppose-- so we're
going to go from one side
and end up with another.
So what I'm going to do is
start from the dot product
of the conditional flow matching
loss and end up with the one
from the flow matching one.
So what I'm going to
compute is the expectation.
And here, I'm going
to say t x1 and x
of the dot product of ut theta
of x and your conditional vector
field.
So ut of x given x1.
So what I'm telling you is by
definition of the expectation--
so this is just a
bunch of integrals.
So this is the integral over
t over x1 and x of ut of theta
of x dot product with the
conditional vector field
ut of x given x1.
And this is over x1 and x so I'm
going to say it's p data of x1.
And then the conditional
probability path x
given x1 dx1, dx, dt.
So far so good?
So here what we
notice is that if we
put this quantity here,
this quantity here,
and if I divide by dt of x and I
do times dt of x, then what I'm
going to recognize is
the marginal vector field
that we have constructed.
So this is going to be equal to
the integral over t integral.
So this integral over x1
is also going to come here.
So integral over t, integral
over x of ut theta of x.
And this ut of x, which is
the marginal vector field,
times this marginal probability
path dt of x, dx, dt.
And this is nothing else
than the expectation over t
and x, which is run from
the marginal probability
path of the dot product
of ut theta of x
and the marginal vector field,
which is exactly what we want.
So what I'm showing you here is
that the marginal vector field,
the way we
constructed it, allows
us to optimize on a loss,
the conditional flow matching
loss, which is much
more tractable,
and leads us to the same
gradients with respect to theta.
And so long story short,
we have this loss,
which is called the conditional
flow matching loss, which
is the expectation over t x1,
which is run over the pdata,
and then x drawn over the
conditional probability
path of a quantity that
is extremely simple.
So it's just the
squared distance
between the learned velocity,
which is what you want to learn,
and the conditional
vector field,
which we saw was nothing
else than just x1 minus x0.
So it's a very
tractable loss, and it
does exactly what you want.
Any questions?
So it's a lot.
Are we all clear with this?
OK, I'm going to say that it's
OK if you feel like it's a lot.
It is indeed a lot.
So I'm going to
recap the strategy.
So what we said at
the very beginning
was that we had
two different views
of how we want to go
from one distribution
to another distribution.
What we said was that there was
this quantity called the vector
field, a.k.a. the velocity that
was linked to how we could move
our particles, so with the ODE
dx over dt equal vector field
that one, but also
the continuity
equation that linked the vector
field with the probability path.
So what we want is to find
the vector field that will
allow us to go from p0 to p1.
So what you need to
do is to find first
a probability path that goes
from p1 to-- sorry, from p0
to p1.
First you need to find that.
And then you need to construct
a vector field that indeed
allows you to go from p0 to p1.
So how do you do--
how do you do that?
Well, you propose
some quantities
and you try to see if the
continuity equation is indeed
satisfied.
So that's step number one.
Once you your vector
field of interest,
your goal now is to learn it.
Because if you learn
it, then what you can do
is to integrate the ODE.
Why do you want to
integrate the ODE?
It's because you want
to go from x0 to x1.
Therefore, you need to
learn your vector field.
And here what we did is, in
order to learn the vector field,
we first thought of
a very simple case
of us wanting to
go from the initial
to a single point via the
conditional probability
path and the conditional
vector field.
So this is the simple case
with the Dirac distribution
being the target distribution.
And then what we said was OK,
given this very simple case that
is super tractable, let's try to
match our initial distribution
with the actual target
one of interest, which
is the whole data distribution,
not just a single point,
but the whole data distribution.
And we proposed the
marginal probability
path which satisfies t equals
0 equals p0 and t equal 1.
It's equal to p data.
So it was a valid
probability path.
And we also saw that the
constructed vector field
was actually generating that
proposed marginal probability
path.
It was generating it, why?
Because it satisfies the
continuity equation, which
I said I don't have
time to derive,
but you just need to
replace the quantities
and see that the continuity
equation is indeed satisfied.
So given that we were finally
with the vector field,
that was something that was
adapted to our use case.
But now what we wanted
to do was to learn it
with the tractable loss.
So in this last
part, what we did
is show that the loss
that we wanted to optimize
was actually equivalent
to another loss that
was extremely tractable, which
is the conditional flow matching
loss.
And the way we showed
that was by showing
that the gradient of this
losses with respect to theta
were equal, which
is what I did here.
And then finally, we have
our final loss function,
which is ut theta of x minus x1
minus x0 expectation of that.
So it's incredibly simple.
So everything I told you is
actually-- so a lot of it
is coming from this paper
that's called Flow Matching
for Generative Modeling.
So I highly
recommend reading it.
It may not be the
simplest to read,
but I hope what I
just told you actually
will allow you to understand the
formulas in there a bit better.
But I didn't want to
give it to Shervine
before telling you a bit
more about why we're calling
this whole thing flow matching.
Because core matching,
it was called core
matching because you
tried to match the score.
But here, we're not
matching the flow,
we're matching the velocity.
So one natural question
is, why is it not
called velocity matching?
Why is it not called
vector field matching?
Why is it called flow matching?
So these points are
a bit more informal.
It's just a personal take
on why that is the case.
So one potential reason
is, historically,
these models which
are flow models,
meaning trying to map a point
to another via this psi t of x
minus 0, they had the
term flow in their names,
and in particular the
method that I mentioned
that try to learn the vector
field with maximum likelihood
estimation.
That one was called
continuous normalizing flows.
So one reason is maybe
branding, but actually, I
want to get back to my earlier
Lipschitz continuity comment.
It turns out that if the vector
field that you learn here
is Lipschitz continuous,
then what happens
is that your trajectories,
they're all unique.
So you actually have a
mapping between vector fields
that you learn and the flow.
So if you're matching
the velocity,
you're also matching the flow.
Now you may be
wondering, OK, how
do that the learned vector field
is indeed Lipschitz continuous?
Well, we have not seen that yet.
We're going to see
that in lecture 5.
But the model that
is behind this
learned vector
field is something
that is composed of
matrix multiplications
and some smooth
activation functions.
All of that is
Lipschitz continuous.
So what you will
learn is actually
Lipschitz continuous
vector field
with respect to
x, which is going
to give you a one-to-one mapping
between velocity and flow.
And we have two minutes.
So bear with me.
In two minutes,
I'm going to cover
how we train and do inference.
But it's going to be very easy.
So let's see how we do training.
So as I mentioned, the
loss is extremely simple.
And so what we do is
we sample the noise.
So x0 from your standard
Gaussian distribution,
your clean image, so
x1 from your training
set, which is pdata, and you
also sample your time step.
And what you do is you
construct xt, your noise image.
And what I'm telling you is
thanks to the loss function
that we derived, what we do is
we use xt, the noise image and t
to predict x1 minus x0, which
is the conditional vector
field via this model that
is your vector field model.
And you're going to compute
the loss and backpropagate.
That's how you do training.
Now, how do you do inference?
Well, inference, you just sample
from an easy data distribution.
And here it's, again,
standard, normal distribution.
And what you're going to do is
to numerically solve the ODE.
So what you do is you go
time step to time step,
and you use your
learned vector fields,
and you end up with your
final estimated image x1.
And that's how you do inference.
And with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So now we're going to see
in a more visual manner
the training process and
discuss some edge cases
and how to solve
them in practice.
So you remember the
training process
that Afshine just mentioned.
You sample x0 from the
normal distribution,
you sample x1 from
your training set.
And what you do is that you draw
a straight line between the two,
and you try to fit the
velocity to this x1 minus x0.
Now I want you to imagine that
we do that for a given pair.
And now for another pair.
And suppose that these pairings
intersect at a given point.
And let's suppose that this
intersection is for a same t.
So in other words, we're trying
to fit the loss at a same x,
at a same T on two
different vectors.
So who knows what the resulting
learned velocity will be?
So it cannot be two
velocities right.
We cannot have two
vectors at a single point.
It has to be one.
So we have this MSE loss
that will make it such
that it will be an
average of all the vectors
that we tried to fit at
that given point points x
and at given point t and you
see that as being a problem
or, so what does that mean?
So here in practice, let's
say you're at inference time
and you want to go from,
let's say, x0 to x1.
And let's say you have learned
a vector fields of velocity that
doesn't go to x1.
That goes in an
average direction.
Are you going to be
able to go to x1?
No, right?
So the thing that will
occur is that you're
going to have something
averaged that might repel
the trajectories that you try to
learn into different directions.
But be reassured,
we showed that these
learned vector fields
was such that if you
sample a point in the
normal distribution
and follow the
learned vector field,
you land into a
distribution land, that will
be your distribution pdata.
So that part is fine.
But still, you
have this property
that the learned
trajectories are not
going to be the same as the
ones that you teach your model.
And that is a source of what
I would call complexity, where
you teach a model
that doesn't follow
what you said at test time.
So that is inherently--
so your intuition could make you
feel that this is not efficient.
And the second thing
that I want to say
is that you could have
this phenomenon happening,
even though the
points of intersection
are not at the exact same T,
because in practice, you're
going to learn this vector
field with a neural network.
And neural network
are going to be
a class of functions that are
going to be smoothing things
in space.
So you won't have a
drastic change of velocity
for neighboring t's.
And so because
one thing that you
could have told me
is, but Shervine,
that is never going to happen.
01 is an interval with
infinitely many numbers.
You're never going to draw the
same t, and you would be right.
And I'm just saying that it
could be valid for neighboring
t's.
And more importantly, let's say
you sample your point x0 out
of your normal distribution.
What is going to
be your issue here?
Afshine mentioned that
you want to integrate
the ODE at inference time.
And we had seen
last time that you
want to find methods that
optimize that number of NFEs
in such a way that you can
find your target sample
in a minimum amount of steps.
And when you have a path
that is getting curved,
so you don't have these straight
lines at inference time,
you're not going to be able to
solve that in a single step.
Because let's say you use Euler.
Euler is estimating the velocity
at the beginning points.
And if you try to do
it in a single step,
it will end up somewhere else.
It will follow a straight
path, whereas the curve isn't
going to be taken into account.
And you're going to tell
me, but Shervine, you
have tricks in your pockets.
Last time you talked
about a DPM solver
in a different setting that
was able to reframe things
in an exact way.
Well, no.
This time, the ODE that
we want to integrate
has no linear components.
It's all non-linear
because here we're directly
learning that velocity field.
So no DPM solver here.
You need to use traditional
sampler techniques.
So not quite happy.
We're happy but not quite.
So now I'm going to walk
you through the intuition
of a retraining or fine tuning
procedure that is called reflow.
And so first I'm going to
recap the training procedure
that we have already.
So you sample a point x0,
you sample a point x1,
you draw a path and then
you fit a velocity on it.
So it is called in that paper
a one rectified flow model.
And you obtain trajectories that
we saw we're going to be curved.
And one idea that we have
here, one temptation,
is to locate these new pairings.
So you started from point x0.
You integrated the ODE.
You ended up at somewhere in
the distribution of pdata.
You're tempted to use these
new pairs as your new pairings,
because they will
be, by construction,
in such a way that the
velocity field will carry
the trajectory directly there.
So the reflow
procedure says, OK,
let's take these
new pairs as those
that we use to
retrain the model.
So this will be our new lines
that we fit our new model.
And so this is the reflow step.
And you do that
process again and again
until your lines
becomes straighter.
And once that is the
case, at inference time,
you're able to use a limited
amount of inference steps
in order to get your
sample in the pdata space.
So does this
procedure make sense?
Yep?
So the comment is
if you retrain, then
the two points are going to
be from the new distribution.
So the magic in all of this--
so first, you're going to keep
that Gaussian distribution
at the beginning.
That will not change.
And at the end,
we're going to see
that there are some
properties that
makes it such that the resulting
points that you get still
preserve the
distribution p data.
So there is some
theoretical justification
that it does follow pdata.
But this is a great point.
We're going to discuss that
in more detail in two slides.
Any other questions or comments?
OK, so you're right
to be skeptical.
So this works because
of two things.
So first, actually, one slide.
So we need to show that this
follows the distribution pdata.
So I'm not going to give
you the whole proof, just
the gist of it.
So you start by defining
this random variable that
starts at x0.
And you integrate the ODE
to end up in the new space
and define this velocity for the
x random variable and the proof
to show that the law that you
get for the end distribution
after a reflow
procedure goes through,
showing that these two
probability flows respect
the same continuity equation.
And with some uniqueness
theorem and the presence
of initial conditions at the
fact that dt equals 0 is still
the Gaussian
distribution, you can
show that it's valid for all t
and, in particular, t equals 1.
So yeah, just hand-waving
the proof here.
So it's theoretically the case.
But you are right
to be skeptical,
because once you
integrate the ODE,
you have errors that
come in from two sources.
So the first error is
the discretization error.
So as we said, we're
sampling these new points.
So maybe you have some errors
in the way you do these steps.
So you don't necessarily end
up in a theoretical location
you should be at.
And the second point is
that you're operating off
of a learned vector field
that is approximated
by a neural network,
and it is possible
that you haven't
learned it perfectly.
I mean, of course
it's sure that you
haven't learned it perfectly.
And the quality of
your results will
be a function of how well
you learn that vector field
and of your
discretization errors.
And we're going to see
very soon that this
is one of the reasons why we
don't perform this procedure too
many times, because the
degradation is going to be
a trade off to balance here.
So this is the first
point I wanted to justify.
The second point I
wanted to justify
is we hand waved the fact that
the flows like the trajectories
were getting
straighter, and there
is a mathematical way of
writing it down and proving it.
And this is also something
that is being proven
in case you're interested.
And for the interest of time,
I'm not going to be covering it,
but that s quantity quantifies
straightness and compares
the actual velocity with
the theoretical one.
And we show that it
decays with a good speed.
And this is why we're saying
it's getting straighter.
And exactly as we discussed,
the reflow procedure
is one that you wouldn't
want to do too many times,
but usually, one procedure
is already great.
And the goal is for us to use a
very simple sampling techniques,
such as Euler, optimally
in just a few steps,
finding the right solution.
And of course, it
isn't a free lunch.
It comes at a trade off.
So you're trading off simplicity
and potentially lower quality
for faster inference
time speeds.
OK, great.
So this past three lectures,
including this one,
we've come across these concepts
of diffusion, score matching,
and now flows, flow matching.
And I want to spend
five minutes together
to tie all of these frameworks
together in a way that
will hopefully show links
between them and the fact
that we are solving the
same category of problems
but from different lenses.
And in order to
do that, I'm going
to look at each of the
processes that we defined
and then look at the difference
with respect to each method.
So the first one is
the forward process.
So it's a long time ago.
Already two weeks ago, we talked
about DPM and all this class
of discrete time, diffusion.
And then we saw in score-based
diffusion world that if you
reframed these equations and
converted it into continuous
time, put some delta t to 0, you
could get some SDE formulation
that was equivalent to it, Where
we saw at the DPM solver section
that actually, in diffusion
space, you could approximate--
I mean, you could always
assume that f of x and t
was linear in x.
And this is why.
So it's something that
we haven't seen so far
but I'm telling you that
you have a nice closed form
expression with respect
to f and g of xt.
And now we saw today
that you can write down
xt as an interpolation between
x0 and x1 in flow matching.
And now we're going to see
that in all of these methods,
you start from a clean sample.
So in a diffusion space, we
start the clean sample from t
equals 0.
But in flow matching
space, we saw
that the notation was reversed.
Clean sample is t equals 1.
And on the other
side of the spectrum,
you have noise, which was in
diffusion world t equals big t.
And here it's t equals 0.
So you're here drawing an
interpolation between the two
in each of these cases.
Now when we look at
the loss functions,
we saw that the diffusion
view of writing things down
was focusing on noise.
The score matching view
was linking scores,
and you had a nice relationship
between noise and score.
And in the flow matching world,
you were directly fitting
the velocity field such
that you have the simplest
ODE to integrate in the end.
Now, when we look at
the generation process,
we saw in the diffusion
world that you
had all these
steps to go through
with some stochasticity,
which you also
had in the score-based
diffusion world,
and you had for the first two,
a deterministic counterpart.
And you will notice
that the flow matching
one doesn't have such
a balance because it's
deterministic to start with.
And I'm just showing you some
relationships between all
these methods, but
actually, there
is a whole theory linking these
concepts in a very nice way.
And this is why I recommend
if you're interested.
So it's out of scope
for this class.
And just if you're interested,
to take a look at the paper
called Stochastic Interpolants
that writes down equations that
links all of these together.
And turns out that r of
noise, score, and velocity,
if you know two of them, you
can deduce the third one.
And that paper designs
a problem space
that is bigger than what each
of these frameworks detailed.
And all of these
frameworks can live
in the same unified framework.
And with that, I hope
you have a great weekend.